ja in der heutigen sitzung werden wir
uns mit fiktionalen objekten und
virtuellen realitäten befassen
aber wie immer geht gibt es einen
rückblick auf die letzten sitzung und in
dieser sitzung hatten wir uns mit pieter
van in wagen und mit kidd verein befasst
das sind gegenwärtige analytische
philosophen aus dem angelsächsischen
raum der linke peter von inhalten der
richtige speed verein und ich mach oben
rechts ein link zu einem vortrag einer
im youtube-video von peter von ihn wegen
über das thema freiheit und diesen
vortrag hatte ja der lmu münchen
vor einiger zeit gehalten was haben
diese beiden denke jetzt über existenz
gesagt wir haben uns folgende frage
gestellt was versteht pieter van in
wegen unter komposition inwiefern
existieren nach von in wenigen tische
und steinen nicht das beste tier nämlich
worin besteht die unter logische
auszeichnung von leben und zugriff 1
haben wir uns gefragt wie fern
existieren nicht existierende dinge
nicht verführen nach kit fallen nicht
existierende dinge ein double live ein
doppelleben das waren die fragen und
jetzt gemäß darauf peter von in welchen
kurz ein
in seinem buch materie libyens hat peter
van weegen eine ganz zentrale these
entwickelt nämlich eine these der
komposition
das betrifft die frage wie materielle
dinge zusammengesetzt sind
und er vertritt jetzt die these dass
materielle teilchen nur dann ein einzel
ding eine substanz bilden die existiert
wenn diese teilchen durch das prinzip
des lebens geeint sind
daraus folgt eben die kontur aktive
these dass künstliche substanzen wie
tisch und stühle die sub stance existing
bei art nennt aber auch substanz systems
also kontingent zufällig existierte
dinge wie stein und holzstücke dass die
nicht eigentlich existieren da sie von
ihren materiellen teilchen nicht durch
das prinzip des lebens strukturiert also
existenz und leben werden bei van weegen
aufs engste aufeinander bezogen leben
ist eine ganz besondere form von
existenz und jetzt sagt von in welchen
tische und steine obwohl sie nur
uneigentlich bzw
metaphorisch existieren können so
existent genannt werden wie wir davon
sprechen dass sich die sonne um die erde
dreht das ist natürlich nicht der fall
sondern die erde dreht sich um die sonne
aber wir sagen ab und zu im alltag dass
sich die sonne um die erde dreht und
genau so können wir nach von ihnen wegen
auch davon sprechen dass dinge wie stein
und tische existieren
was ist jetzt der grund davon dass sie
nicht so existieren wie lebewesen
lebewesen die tragende identitäts
prinzip in sich und sind durch
regeneration wie zum beispiel die
heilung von wunden und die nachbildung
von stoffwechsel ausgezeichnet dadurch
zeichnen sich eben lebewesen aus sie
haben ein ganz besonderes existenzen
identitäts prinzip und das haben jetzt
steine und tische nicht das ist die ja
etwas provokative these von peter von
den wegen aber er hat gute argumente
dafür existenz so streng zu fassen und
existenz irgendwie auch an identität
ganz streng zu binden
das ist seine these und jetzt kann man
noch auf die these von gipf
einzusprechen bezüglich existenz dieser
philosoph unterscheidet jetzt bezüglich
nicht existierende gegenstände
verschiedene positionen die endplatten
ismus empirismus liberalismus kontext
tourismus interna liz muss und extern
da sind seine positionen und jetzt
wollen wir uns immer genauer anschauen
also die frage ist eben die wie
existieren fiktive oder allgemeiner
gesagt nicht existierende gegenstände
mit fiktiven gegenständen werden und
sitzen dieser sitzung noch näher
befassen der plattform ismus das ist die
these nach find das nicht existierende
gegenstände wie zb fiktionen nicht von
physischen oder psychischen empirischen
vorgängen abhängen sondern
notwendigerweise existieren dem
entgegengesetzt ist der empirismus der
besagt nicht existierende gegenstände
wie fiktionen sind von der passion
realität ihres erfinders der finderin
abhängig psychologisch und empirisch und
existieren daher nur kontingente weise
weitere position ist der liberalismus
fiktive gegenständen wie zum beispiel
sherlock holmes haben ihre an gedichten
eigenschaften wirklich und an sich als
im wörtlichen sinne sowie ist an einem
buch steht litera wirklich am kontext
tourismus dagegen sagt fiktive figuren
wie sherlock holmes haben ihre an
gedichten eigenschaften nur im kontext
der erzählungen in denen sie auftreten
also kontext realismus ist ein
relativismus sozusagen existenz und
eigenschaften nur eben in der fiktion im
raum der fiktion ist kann man sich
natürlich fragen wie existieren
fiktionen erzählungen welche unter
logischen status haben die eine weitere
position die er ins spiel bringt ist er
im tennis muss fiktive gegenstände wie
sherlock holmes werden durch ihre
internen eigenschaften individualisiert
und diese eigenschaften besitzen sie im
kontext in denen sie erscheinen
sie sehen gleich das ist ganz ähnlich
wie der kontext journalismus weil es um
den zusammenhang geht in dem eben die
fiktive figur ihre eigenschaften besitzt
oder nicht haben wir haben nach dem
intern alles muss nur innerhalb dieser
kontexte zugang zu diesen eigenschaften
dann gibt es auch den extremismus
natürlich entgegen gesetzt
journalismus der extremismus besagt
fiktive gegenstände wie sherlock holmes
können nicht durch interne in fiktionale
eigenschaften sondern nur durch externe
außer fiktionale eigenschaften
individuen und bestimmt werden wir
können nur durch die äußere wirkliche
welt die externe welt wirklichen zugang
die eigenschaften des gegenstandes haben
wie die psychologische beziehung gehört
des autors zu seinem werk das ist jetzt
natürlich sehr ähnlich dem in paris muss
im gegensatz zum plateau liz muss das
wird jetzt geht feind zu der these das
fiktionale gegenstände wie eben die
figur des sherlock holmes ein doppeltes
leben ein doppelleben ein double live
führen
auf der einen seite haben fiktionale
gegenstände ihre eigenschaften nur in
den kontexten als infektionen oder
geschichten in denen sie auftreten
auf der anderen seite sind sie auch mit
der wirklichen welt verbunden sie sind
durch ihre autorinnen und autoren
erschaffen worden
wir werden später noch sehen dass es die
position des kreationismus ist
hinsichtlich der ontologie von fiktiven
gegenständen und die fiktiven figuren
werden durch die leser rezipiert und vor
dem eigenen geistigen auge erschaffen
also jede leserin jeder leser wenn sie
jetzt ein buch liest zum beispiel schon
kommt dann erschafft sie gewissermaßen
diese figur vor dem geistigen auge und
sie trägt sie erzeugt durch die
einbildungskraft diese ganze fiktionale
welt ohne den lisa könnte man sagen nach
dieser position
er würde sherlock holmes gar nicht
existieren durch irgendeine rezipienten
die den sinn versteht und die sich diese
welt vorstellen kann durch imagination
durch einbildungskraft das ist also
diese doppelte existenz von fiktiven
gegenständen und wir sehen für tiefe
gegenstände hängen ganz eng mit anderen
spannenden fragen bezüglich der existenz
zusammen vor allem mit solchen fragen
wie unmöglich
gegenstände die wir bei alex meinung
kennengelernt habe nicht nach oben
rechts auch noch mal ein link zu dieser
sitzung und aber auch zu virtuellen
realitäten mit der wir es in der
heutigen sitzung dann zu tun bekommen
werden